all right everyone special Halloween
edition Nina and I are off to a salsa
party that we're hosting and I've got to
teach a lesson ad and phase one of my
zombie costume was fina do makeup
nothing brings Nina more joy than be
able to put makeup on me it doesn't
happen that often once a year more than
what's here we were done at base nice
halloween I think once a year it's a
highlight of her year she loves putting
makeup on me and otherwise not a fan
except for Halloween so this is blood
and tiredness and I got to get my
costume on and then we're gonna rock the
Halloween party all right here we are in
full costume Evan the zombie security
guard Nina the slasher star and
Stephanie my sister the female Robin
Robin doesn't do that pretty sure
Bobby's not dude I piece okay oh we
gotta take a picture I'm trying to do
I'm trying to start a thing doing a
picture of the day okay this is the
first day do it okay okay let's go
dancing get ready all right we're apt at
the club there's a few performances
happening behind us
anybody sent me where you want to be in
here DJ romantico wanna Toronto's
hottest salsa DJ's right there I like it
so once these guys finish the
performance do the lesson and then get
dancing
you
and
you
the winner of our five years of how does
the ball return your eyes
No
here's a try
I'm back it was an amazing night it is
almost 1230 I gotta be up in five and a
bit hours to go to the League of Legends
finals that's being strained here in
Toronto at a big theater and I gotta
figure out how to think all this makeup
off this is great makeup actually not
that I'm a huge fan of makeup but
usually the stuff I had before I think
was paint a couple years ago and that it
was really sticky and this is actually
pretty cool it even I was on and I
touched my face every now and then I
have to worry about touching my face
look there's Nina wake up get the league
of legends get some coffee in the
morning and I have a great day hope you
guys have an amazing weekend and I was
like you see Nina how do I get this off
with I don't know you know how to get
such wash it with Facebook just normal
soap you don't use baby wipes or
something I feel anything I told you
this a white makeup remover wipes on the
tongue clinic in the washroom okay